[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوايا
[موسيقى]
صوت الطالبات يعلو في كابول رفضا لحظر
التعليم الجامعي ومجموعه السبع تحذر جريمه
ضد الانسان
[موسيقى]
لبريطانيا بوقف ترحيل اللاجئين لرواندا
والعربيه تلتقي طالب اللجوء في لندن
وفي القضايا التي شغلت موقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه تتابعنا ايضا
شركاء ومؤسس منصه اف تي اكس للعملات
الرقميه المشفره يعترفون بالذنب في تهم
الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
جوا وبرا وبحرا بهذه الكلمات تعهد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
الهجمات الروسيه على اوكرانيا
فرض الولايات المتحده عقوبات على كيانات
بحريه روسيه ياتي في اعقاب الهجمات
البحريه التي تشنها موسكو على الموانئ
الاخرىنيه شبكه سي ان ان تحدثت عن
المخرجات الرئيسيه لصفقه حيث وصفت انظمه
صواريخ وهي انضمام معقده ودقيقه ومكلفه
بانها المعيار الذهبي للدفاع الجوي في
الولايات المتحده لكن
اخر خرج اليوم ليوضح ان انظمه قديمه ولا
تعمل مثل الانظمه الروسيه 3 مضيفا سنحطم
منظمات
وسيحتاج الغرب الى جلب اسلحه اخرى كما اكد
ان الولايات احد منخرطه في الصراع
باوكرانيا منذ زمن طويل مشيرا الى ان
واشنطن ساعدت في وصول قوميين متطرفين
للسلطه في اوكرانيا
ولا تعمل كما تعمل انظمه اس 300 مثلا ومع
ذلك من يجابه هنا ينطلق من ان هذا السلاح
دفاعي سنخذ هذا في الحسبان ببساطه وسنجد
له ترياقا ومن يفعل ذلك يبطل ابدا فقط
سنحطم منظومه باتريات وسيحتاج الغرب الى
جلب اسلحه اخرى
واضاف الرئيس الروسيبلاديمير بوتن ان هدف
بلاده ليس تاجيج الحرب للسعي الى انهائها
مؤكدا ان روسيا تثق في تحقيق اهدافها في
اوكرانيا ولمجال للتراجع وفقه تعبير
هدفون
اليه طورنا اسلحه الجيش الروسي للدفاع
وليس الهجوم سنزيد من قدراتنا العسكريه
باضافه اسلحه متطوره مع بدايه السنه روسيا
تثق في تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا ولا
مجال للتراجع
اذا زياره تاريخيه للرئيس الاوكراني
فولودي ميرزلنسكي الى واشنطن يبدو انها
حققت المطلوبه الدعم الامريكي السخيه
يتواصل والصمود ثابت عقب مرور 300 يوما من
الحرب خلال الزياره اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
جوبايدن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لكيف
بحوالي مليارات دولار اهم فيها تزويد
اوكرانيا بمنظومه صواريخ باتشيات التي
ستحمي سماء البيت
يغير واقع الحرب التفوق الروسي الحالي
الوحيد في اوكرانيا هو سلاح الصواريخ
المدمره التي من شان تفعيل هذه المنظومه
ان تنهي هذا التوافق او تحدي منه بشكل
كبير على الاقل
نظري
عن حزمه جديده من الدعم الدفاعي حوالي
ملياريه دولار امريكي واقوى عنصر في هذه
الحزمه هو انظمه صواريخ باترون امر من
شانه ان يعزز الدفاع عن الجويه بشكل كبير
هذه خطوه مهمه للغايه لشيء مجال جوي امن
الاوكرانيا وهذه هي الطريقه الوحيده التي
ستمكننا من حرمان الدوله
الرئيس الامريكي حمل نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن المسؤوليه الكامله عن
استمرار الصراع في اوكرانيا وفاتوره الحرب
القاسيه امر رفضه الكراملين ورده الى
واشنطن التي اتهمها بدخول حرب غير مباشره
ضد روسيا
والولايات المتحده ملتزمه بضمان استمرار
الشعب الاوكراني الشجاع في الدفاع عن
بلاده ضد العدوان الروسي طالما استغرق
الامر ذلك
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور محمد
مجاهد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك دكتور
محمد يعني اعلان تزويد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا بنظام باتريوت الى اي
حد قد يغير بقواعد اللعبه على الارض وكيف
ما الذي سيتغير
دلوقتي المتحده بمنظومه بترول اوكرانيا لم
يكن قرار مفاجئا فيتم التدريب منذ اكثر من
شهرين لكوادر اوكرانيه في رومانيا وفي
المانيا على هذه المنظومه وهي دي اخر حلقه
في منظمه الدفاع الجوي التي قدمتها الدول
العربيه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا هذه المنظومه الحديث عن تاثيرها
في ميدان التوازن العسكري القائم حاليا
حاليا ان نعرف كم منظومه سيتم الامداد بها
سمعنا انها منظومه واحده يعني توضع في
مكان واحد لكن
التغيير الحرب او تاثير على العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه خاصه الصواريخ همم التي
تضرب الاماكن والمواقع الحيويه يحتاج الى
منظومات كبيره لا اعتقد ان القرار يتضمن
ذلك النقطه الثانيه ان الكوادر الاوكرانيه
لم تتلقى التدريب الكافي حتى الان على
تشغيل تلك المنظومه بما يجعلنا ان نقول
انها رمزيه حتى الان اوعى في التقييم
النهائي ان لن تغير من العمليات العسكريه
تلقائمه او من الموازين العسكريه القائمه
في الحرب الجاريه الان لانها على الاقل هي
منظومه دفاع جوي ضد الصواريخ هذه الصواريخ
ربما تكون صواريخ يعني فيرت صوتيه لا
اعتقد ان النظام باتريك قادر على منعها
وفي اماكن متعدده النقطه الثانيه ان روسيا
تركز على وسيلتين الصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره والبتروت لا يمكن ان يتصور انه
سلاحا لمواجهه طيران
لماذا زودت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
همم اوكرانيا بهذه المنظومه من الصواريخ
ان كانت باعداد قليله لانه مثل ماذا كانت
هناك حديث عن منظومه واحده او بطاريه
واحده وان كانت غير فعاله على المسيارات
يعني حتى انه هناك ضجه حولها لماذا
يعني يعني هي قدمتها كنوع من الدعم
المعنوي للرئيس الاوكراني
ولاستمرار الموقف الامريكي ضد العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه هذا على المستوى السياسي
اما على المستوى العسكري فربما تكون
المقصود بها تامين اكثر المناطق حيويه في
اوكرانيا او في العاصمه يعني على هذا
الاساس لان هناك عده انظمه للدفاع الجوي
تم امدادها معظم وافضل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
في المانيا وفي بريطانيا وفي فرنسا قدمت
حتى من السويد قدمت الى اوكرانيا وتستخدم
البترول هي اضافه لكنها لن تغير من موازين
العمليه العسكريه الفتره القادمه ستركز
على العمليات الجويه مع دخول الشتاء
وبالتالي مطلوب اوكرانيا تسعى الى ان تؤمن
القوات الموجوده في الجبهه والتي تواجه اا
روسيا خاصه منطقه دونسك وتجعل ال- ال-
روسيا تراجع نفسها في دخول القوات الجويه
بالتحديد لعمليه قصر نعمته ممكن تهدد
العمليات الجويه ولكنها لن تغير من ميزان
العسكري بصفه كبيره ابقى معي يا دكتور
محمد همم اكدت مشاهدينا وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينا بايربوك كان وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع اتفقوا على اهميه دعم
اوكرانيا بمنظمات دفاع جويه نظرا لاهميتها
لحفظ الارواح وقال تعاقبه اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع ان المانيا ترحب
بقرار واشنطن ارساله منظومات للدفاع الجوي
الى اوكرانيا
لنستعرض معكم مشاهدينا حجم المساعدات التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا منذ
بدء الحرب والتي تجاوزت 24 مليار دولار من
بين هذا خائر مدفعيه وذخائر لانظمه صواريخ
سام للدفاع الجوي وانظمه هذه التي شكلت
فريقا في الحرب بينما يستعد الكونجرس
لاقرار مشروع قانون الميزانيه العامه
للدوله الفيدراليه والذي يتضمن مساعدات
جديده لاوكرانيا تبلغ قيمتها
44.9 مليار دولار ارقام ضخمه لحرب قد تعيد
رسم خريطه
الحاله تصدرت قائمه الداعمين الولايات
المتحده مع 19.6 مليار دولار قدمت على شكل
معدات واسلحه عسكريه واربع فاصل سته مليار
دولار مساعدات ماليه عسكريه ليبلغ
المساعدات حتى الان 24 فاصل اثنين مليار
دولار ابرز الاسلحه الامريكيه كانت انظمه
هايمرز ومدافع الهودزر وصواريخ جافلن
المحموله على الكتف اضافه الى كميه ضخمه
من الذخائر المتنوعه بريطانيا حلت ثانيه
في قائمه الزعيمين مع تقديمها معدات
واسلحه بقيمه مليارا دولار اضافه الى
اثنين فاصل ثلاثه مليار دولار كمساعدات
الماليه
باجمالي بلغ اربعه فاصل ثلاثه مليار دولار
بينها مدافعها وصواريخ جافنن اما المانيا
فقدمت اثنين فاصل اربعه مليار دولار كم
عداد واسلحه تضمنت مدرعات
المانيه وصواريخ سنجر المحمول على الكتف
امريكا السرعه
الجاره بولندا بحجم المساعدات قدمت
مساعدات قدرت بمائه او 1.9 مليار دولار
اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه مثل ما ذكرنا اضافه
الى اسهامات اخرى من كندا و انروج وسوايد
والدمرك واتشيك اما فرنسا في حلت بالمرتبه
الاخيره مع تقديمها نصف مليار دولار معدات
عسكريه واسلحه فقط وذلك بسبب تخوف رئيسها
ايمانويل من اهانه روسيا وفقا
دكتور محمد اهلا بك من جديد يعني الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من خلال تزويدها
اوكرانيا بهذا النظام نظام هل هي مستعده
لتحمل التبعات لانه الكريم اعتبر اليوم
بانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي الان
بحرب غير مباشره مع روسيا التبعات
الداخليه والخارجيه لانه حتى الداخل
الامريكي الجمهوريين يعني عندهم تحفظات
كبيره على الدعم الكبير المادي ليه
اوكرانيا
الجزء الاول في السؤال وهو ال ال
الروسي تعتبر ان تقديم الباتروت معناها
التورد في الحرب هذه منذ بدايه الحرب
وروسيا تقول لهذا الامر لكن انا في ال
القضيه الاساسيه
بالمشاركه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الفعليه في الحرب هي استنزاف القدرات
العسكريه المتقدمه والمتطوره لروسيا في
تقديري ان تقديم البترول سوف يضطر روسيا
لتدميرها باستخدام الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه
وهي كميات ليست كبيره وهو هدف رئيسي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تستنفه
وبالتالي هي انت تستمر الحرب ويستمر
الاستنزاف لروسيا ويستسم يستمر
الاسلحه الاكثر تطورا والاكثر احداثه فيما
يتعلق في الجزء الثاني الخاص بالجمهوريه
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك تاثير
الاغلبيه العدديه للحزب الجمهوري فيما
يتعلق بعمليه اقرار الميزانيه القادمه
وحسبه المساعدات التي قبلت بحالي 44 مليار
دولار لاوكرانيا هتكون هناك تساؤلات كبيره
حول هذا الموضوع ولا يرجح ان يتم اقرار
هذه المزانيه او هذا الدعم بهذا المستوى
ولكن دكتور محمد يعني امام كل هذا الدعم
الكبير العسكري والمادي هذه المليارات
التي تقدم لي سيلنسكي واوكرانيا هل
ستقف همم روسيا مكتوفه الايدي ام انه ذلك
سيحفف سباق التسلح الحاصل الان
سباق التزلج يجري على قدم وساق وقد ذكر
تقريركم قبل الحلقه كيف ان روسيا تتحدث عن
تطوير قدرات عسكريه اخرى وزياده مساعدات
عسكريه واعتمادات عسكريه لتطوير قدراتها
خاصه في مجال الاسلحه الاكثر تطورا
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والغرب ياخذون روسيا الى مزيد من سباق
التسلح الذي يمكن ان ينعكس على مزيد من
التوتر ويمكن ان يبدا مواجهات حلف الناتو
حتى الان والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
يبقى امامها في دعم اوكرانيا غير تقديم
صواريخ لضرب القناطر الاراضي الروسيه وهو
ما سوف يعني دخول الطرفي الطرف دخولهم
طرفا مباشره في الحرب وينزل بمواجهه
مباشره في المستقبل
شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره الدكتور محمد
مجاهد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري الفكري
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
خلال زياره الرئيس الاوكراني الى الكونغرس
الامريكي التي وصفت بالتاريخيه اتخذ نائبا
عن الحزب الجمهوري موقفا مخالفا لما اجمع
عليه زملائهم اذ رفض النائبان لوران بوبرد
ومات جيتس الوقوف او التصفيق للرئيس
الاوكراني خلال خطابه امام الكونغرس وعلى
الرغم من ان نزلتك تلقى ترحيبا حارا من
اعضاء الكونغرس بعد ختام خطابه حول الحرب
على اوكرانيا بدا العدوان الجمهوريان غير
متاثرين اثباقيه النائبان جالسين واستمر
في النظر الى هواتفه معا بينما صفق بقيه
اعضاء المجلس للرئيس الاوكراني عند
انتهائه من خطابه التاريخيه
ابرين
[تصفيق]
تويتر
ويحمي حدود البلاد الجنوبيه في اشاره الى
الحدود مع المكسيك وازمه المهاجرين
اسبوع
على ان المناورات العسكريه المشتركه مع
روسيا امر ضروري للتصدي لاي مخاطر
مستقبليه شرف اجتماعا مع القاده العسكريين
الى ان خطره توجيه الحرب نحو بلا روسيا
قائم ولا يمكن استبعاده ويجب الاستعداد له
اذا كنت تريد السلام عليك الاستعداد للحرب
انا لم اقتنع ذلك ولم تقم انت بذلك ايضا
اريدك ان ترد على الشائعات التي انتشرت في
مجتمعنا ولا سيما عبر الانترنت بشان
تحركات القوات البيلاروسيا واولئك الذين
انضموا للقوات المسلحه الروسيه بلا روسيه
لان نستطيع استعاده فكره ان العدوان قد
يستهدف بلندنا على الاقل نستطيع رؤيه
الدول المجاوره مستعده لذلك
ينظر الكثيرون الى تصرفات بوتن على انها
رغبه في اشعال الحرب وكانه الرجل صراعات
لكن خبراء يفسرون ذلك باعتباره سياسه حافه
الهاويه التي يسعى من خلالها
مستعملها الى تحقيق مكاسب في الميدان من
خلال تصعيد الازمات
في عالم السياسه وعلمها حافه الهاويه
تهديد واستعداد بدخول حرب لا تبقي ولا تذر
انها اسلوب في اداره الازمات يلامس سقف
المجهول وتحقيق مكاسب معينه من خلال تصعيد
الازمات ودفع الاحداث الى حدود الصراع مع
الهام الخصم بالاستعداد للتنازل او الردوخ
حتى لو ادى الامر الى السقوط في هاويه
الحرب والدمار
الى حافه الهاويه دون الدخول في الحرب من
ابرز الامثله على استخدام السياسه حافه
الهاويه بين الدول ازمه الصواريخ الكوبيه
والنزاع الذي اشتعل بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من جهه والاتحاد السوفيتي حينها
وكوبا من جهه ثانيه
مراقبون يعتبرون تصرفات بوتان تدخل في
اطار هذه السياسه الرجل ما فتى يهدد
باستخدام كافه الاساليب في ساحه المعركه
ولمواجهه الخصوم باستعمال الاسلحه النوويه
فهو يبدو كرجل حرب في نظر البعض لكن
العارفين بعالم السياسه يقولون انه تهديد
فقط لجنيه مكاسب على طاوله التفاوض
بلال الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
في تحديده اولويات جيشه لعام 2023 تعهد
بوتن بمواصله تعزيز القدرات العسكريه بما
في ذلك النوويه ومنذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا انتشر الحديث عن استخدام السلاح
النوويه جول هذا الحديث هو التاكيد على
عدم استخدام السلاح ولكن النفي في حد ذاته
يشير الى احتماليه احتماليه موجوده فما هو
سيناريو الحرب النوويه مجله نيتشر وضعت
سيناريو التخيلي تبدا فيه الحرب النوويه
بعيدا عن الطرفين الاشهر الولايات المتحده
وروسيا ولكن بين لاعبين غير متوقعين
لاسباب قوميه هنا الحرب بين باكستان
والهند
[تصفيق]
تبدا الازمه في هذا السيناريو عام
اشتباكات في منطقه كشمير المتنازع عليها
بين البلدين مع ازدياد التوتر تبدا دوله
في تفجير عده قنابل نوويه فترد الاخرى
بالمثل عدد القنابل المتفجره في هذا
السيناريو هو 100 من كل دوله اي 200 قنبله
في المجموعه
كل قنبله بحجم قنبلات هيروشيما الاثر
المباشر هو 21 مليون شخص في تلك المنتقه
من العالم المقتضي بالسكان كما ستدمر مئات
المدن بعد ذلك يرتفع الدخان كما نشاهد
عاليا في الغلاف الجوي في الكوكب بغطاء من
الرماد فيحجب اشعه الشمس ليغرق كوكبنا في
بروده عميقه سنوات
يطلق عليه الخبراء اسم الشتاء النووي هنا
نتحدث عن حرب النوويه بين قوتين لا تمتلك
احدهما اكثر من 150 راس نوويه هذا الشتاء
سيؤدي الى فشل المحاصيل في عشرات البلدان
وبالتالي الامدادات الغذائيه لاكثر من
مليار شخص حول العالم هؤلاء سيتاثروا
اما المحيط فليس احسن حالا ستتغير كيمياء
المياه لتصبح حمضيه
فتموت الشعب المرجانيه التي تحافظ على
النظام البيئي وستمت الاسماك مصدر غذاء
اخر لم يعد موجوده
اما السيناريو الاخر فهو الحرب النوويه
الكامله بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه النتيجه كارثيه صدقوني سيرتفع
10050 مليون طن من الرماد في الغلاف الجوي
وسط تنخفض درجات الحراره العالميه باكثر
من عشر درجات مئويه وبعد عامين من هذه
الحرب ستؤدي السماء المظلمه الى عكس اتجاه
الرياح سيصيب الجفاف الشديد مناطق عده في
العالم ومناطق اخرى ستتعرض لامطار غزيره
وسيول مدمره بالنسبه للغذاء ستنهار مناطق
خلال الغذاء سلال الخبز العالميه في الغرب
اوسط في الولايات المتحده وايضا في
اوكرانيا احتياطات الحبوب التي نعرفها
ستختفي في غضون عاما او عمل سيكون الامر
اسوء من اي مجاعه في التاريخ الذي نعرفه
تقول مجله نيتشر ان المحصل نهائيا للحرب
التي يستخدم فيها الانسان فقط واحد بالمئه
من الترسانه الموجوده لديه حاليا
ستدمر الامدادات الغذائيه على كوكب الارض
وحول مصير الانسان فيعتقد اننا لن ننقرض
سيبقى عدد قليل منا من البشر على هذا
الكوكب لكنهم سيكونون منهكين لانهم
سيبداون ببناء حضاره ولكن من
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
منظمات حقوقيه تحذر من اعدام نحو 60 محتجا
في ايران وتهديدات للفنانين والممثلين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ارتفع او ارتفاع الاسعار
مشاهدينا في فرنسا يدفع اسرا الى خفض
استهلاك ما تسبب بتراجع الانفاق
الاستهلاكي بنحو اثنين فاصل ثمانيه في
المئه الشهر الماضي
ترتفعوا تكاليف المعيشه في فرنسا بسبب
التضخم ارتفاع يبدو ملحوظا في اسعار
المواد الغذائيه وصل في بعض الاحيان الى
40 في المئه وفرض خيارات صعبه على
المواطنين من بين تلك الخيارات ان الاسر
اصبحت تستغني عن بعض المنتجات او تلجا الى
منتجات اقل جوده وذلك من اجل الاقتصاد
كل جزء اكبر بحدود 25 خلينا نقول 25 30
مجبرون على زياده اسعارهم لان الموردين
رفعوا اسعار المنتجات عليهم وهذا تسبب
بتداعيات مباشره على حجم مبيعاتهم
ل بعض المنتجات لا يمكننا السيطره على
ارتفاع اسعارها ولذلك اجبرنا على رفع
اسعارنا بنحو 50% وخفض الكميات بيانات
المعهد الوطنيه للاحصاء والدراسات في
فرنسا اظهرت تراجع الانفاق الاستهلاكي
بنحو اثنين فاصل ثمانيه في المئه في شهر
اكتوبر الماضي تراجع تعزه الحكومه الى
سياق تاثر بالحرب في اوكرانيا وما سببته
من زياده في اسعار الطاقه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
تاياني انما يحدث في ايران فقط كل
التصورات
واضافت يعني نقلت وكاله فاليطاليه انه
سيقوم باستدعاء السفير الايراني الى وزاره
الخارجيه عندما يتولى منصبه في روما
معتبرا ان ما يحدث في ايران غير مقبول وفق
تعبيره
ومدن على احتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران التي
دخلت شهرها الرابع اعلن العشرات من
الممثلين والمشاهير الايرانيين عن تضمنهم
مع المتظاهرين بالمقابل يهدد رئيس مؤسسه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون الايرانيه بمن جبلي
بمعقبه الممثلين الايرانيين الذين يعلنون
دعمهم للايرانيين في احتجاجاتهم الشعبيه
[موسيقى]
تجمع عشرات النساء امام جامعه كابو
للاحتجاج في اول مظاهره كبيره تشهد على
العاصمه منذ قرار طالبان حضر دخول
الطالبات
تطالبنا بفتح الجامعات واكدنا ان التعليم
يعتبر
نادره في افغانستان
ما تفضها الاجهزه الامنيه بالقوه
[موسيقى]
يا حبيبي
فيما انسحب طلاب جامعيون من امتحاناتهم
احتجاجا على قرارات طالبان بمنع النساء من
التعليم الجامعي كما قدم عدد من الاساتذه
الذكور استقالاتهم من الجامعات بسبب قرار
الحركه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقام عناصر من حركه طالبان بطرد النساء
والفتيات من المكتبه العامه في كابول كجزء
من قرار الحركه الجديده بمنع النساء من
اكمال تعليمهن الجامعي
واقفه قرار حضر حركه طالبان التعليم
الجامعي للنساء في افغانستان الى اجل غير
مسمى ردود فعل دوليه مستنكره للخطوه التي
اعتبرتها دواء الغربيه ومنظمات الامميه
تضييقا على حريه النساء ومنعا لحقهن
الاساسي في التعليم وقالت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان لينا باير بوكس في بيان
نيابه عن وزراءها في مجموعه الدول السبع
ان اضطهاد النوع الاجتماعي قد يصل الى حد
ارتكاب جريمه ضد الانسان
طالبان تحرق يوما بعد يوم وبيدها لا بيد
غيرها قردا تلو الاخر لانهاء عزلتها
الدوليه
فالحركه التي ظهرت والى التسعينيات من
القرن الماضي الى ان برز نجمها في
افغانستان خليفه عام
1994 الى الان تعيد دوران عقارب الساعه
عكس اتجاهها
حكم الطالبان افغانستان للمره الاولى في
الفتره من
1996 وحتى العام 2001 ووعدت حينها باحلال
السلام والامن والاحترام حقوق الانسان
بمجرد وصولها للسلطه ذلك ما لم يتحقق حضر
الطالبان مشاهده التلفزيون والاستماع الى
الموسيقى وارتياد الدور السينما ورفضت
الذهاب الفتيات من سن العاشره الى المدارس
ودخلت الحركه في عزله دوليه كبيره تمت
الاطاحه حينها بطالبان ولاحقتها تهم
ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
ودخلت في حرب الواسعه النطاق ثم لا حسوا
الحركه مجددا خلال سنوات القليله الماضيه
في افغانستان حيث توفرت فرصه اخرى في ظل
محاوله الغرب دعمها وخلق مساحه للمفاوضات
عادت الحركه الجديده عقبا سحاب القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد العام الماضي
وبسطت سيطرتها بالكامل وفي خضم اعاده دم
الحركه كان الحديث في ذلك الوقت المطالبه
بتقديم المساعده من المجتمع الدولي وفق
تعهدات للمجتمع الافغاني والعالمي وهي
تعهدات لم تحقق منها الحركه شيئا ومنها ما
تم مؤخرا من حظر الدراسه الجامعيه على
الفتيات
هو كان التاريخ يعيد نفسه من جديد اضاع
الطالبان فرصه من يدها وقطعت شوط اخر
للوراء عصام عبد السلام العربيه
اهلا بك سيده صغير يعني
طالبان بررت قرارها هذا همم بانها لا تريد
التخالق بين الرجال والنساء بين الطلاب
والطالب بالمقابل اليوم عمدت الى اغلاق
معهد للطالبات النساء فقط الفتيات كيف
تقراين هذه الازدواجيه وكيف ستتعاملون مع
قرار طالبان هذا
قماش
يبدو انا السيده
[موسيقى]
اللوم على النساء
انتم نايمه ما تعملوش لايكاتك
مني دراستنا
لماذا قاموا بهذا العمل هذا العمل مرفوع
ان يتعلم العلم من المهدي الى اللحد
طيب
هناك اوضاع همم فتيات لطالبات يعني يوم
امس استقبلنا
طالبه هي بالسنه الرابعه يعني سنه التخرج
في الجامعه هل تلك الطالبات لديهن القدره
مثلا على اخذ
درجاتهن ربما ل يكون ربما يعني لخطط اخرى
همم يعني ما الذي يحصل الان
هو زياده القرار الجديده
[موسيقى]
ينهي البعض الجامعه ويتخرج
طيب سيده ثغر يعني
ما خططكم لمواجهه هذا القرار اليوم كان
هناك احتجاجات ولكنها يعني باعداد محدوده
الى حد ما ب- كابول باختصار لو سمحتي
بانا زلمه
[موسيقى]
حسن كامل
بمظاهرات ولكن تعرضنا للضرب مثلا
فضلي
[موسيقى]
حتى المفاوض الجديد لحقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده فولكارك الحكومه البريطانيه
على اعاده النظر في خطتها لترحيل طالب
اللجوء الى رواندا داخليا اعتبر تاييد
المحكمه العليا في لندن ترحيل المهاجرين
غير الشرعيه الى رواندا انتصارا كبيرا
لوزاره الداخليه التي تصر على ان سياسه
الترحيل ضروريه لوقف ازمه القوارب الصغيره
المميته القادمه من فرنسا فيما يدرس
المدافعون عن اللاجئين تقديم الطعن في
القرار الذي سيمدد المعركه القضائيه لحسن
ابعاد اللاجئين الى البلد الافريقي
طالب اللجوء الكردي صباح حسن من بين الذين
يواجهون امكانيه الترحيل الى رواندا بعد
انقضت المحكمه العليا في لندن بقانونيه
ابعاد مهاجرين دخلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير
نظاميه الى العاصمه الروانديه والنظر في
ملفات لجوءهم هناك اللاجئون والمنظمات
المعنيه بشئونهم عبروا عن قلقهم الشديد
ايذاء هذا القرار
بصراحه هذا قرار سيء جدا
ستكون امنه او غيره امنه هذه المجموعه
الكرديه من طالب اللجوء اتت لتستفسر من
احد اعضاء الجمعيه الكرديه لندن بشان
تداعيات تاييد المحكمه العليا لتسويه
طلبات الراغبين باللجوء على بعد الاف
الاميال من بريطانيا
لحقوق الانسان
قبل ذلك فالمصار القضائي ليس نهائيا
القرار
الخطه المثيره للانتقادات بابعاد الاجئين
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير نظاميه الى
رواندا تبنتها حكومه جونسون باتفاقيه مع
نظيرتها في كيغالي لوقف رحلات عبور البحر
الخطيره لالاف المهاجرين من فرنسا الى
الجزيره البريطانيه ترحيل اول دفعه من
ثمانيه لاجئين الغيت الصيف الماضي بعد
تدخل المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان لكن
وزيره الداخليه السولارما مصره على مواصله
سياسه الترحيل في اقرب وقت ممكن
تبيعات هذا القرار غير الانساني وفور وصول
اللاجئين لايوائهم قد ينقلون الى بلد لا
نعرفها
كسب وزاره الداخليه تاييد المحكمه لنقل
اللاجئين الى افريقيا للبث في طلباتهم
يضعوا على طريق تنفيذ خطتها التي لا تزال
حبر على ورق وكلفت دفع الضرائب حتى الان
120 مليون جنيه وقد تتطلب عده اشهر
لتنفيذها بعد انتهاء المسار القضائي مصطفى
زارو العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ازمه العملات
السوق الصاعده بل وجهت لها ضربه قسمه على
الاقل حاليا وبعد اعتقال مؤسس الشركه
سامبا
قبل ايام اعلن المدعي الامريكي داميان
ويليامز ان المؤسس المشارك
والمدير التنفيذي السابقه لشركه الميدا
للابحاث كارولاين اليسون اعترف بالذنب في
تهامه
وذلك اقر بنك في ازمه الشركه التي هزت
السوق المشفره وحولت الرجل بين ليله
وضحاها من مليار الى الرجل لا يملك شيئا
تبخرت ثروه مؤسس البالغه 25 مليار دولار
خلال اسبوع وبقى المستثمرون حائرون من اين
وكيف
سيستعدون ما لهم ان استطاعوا بالاساس
[موسيقى]
وكانت لجنه الاوراق الماليه والبورسات
رفعت شكوى مدنيه ضد وانغو والسن زعيمه
انهما متورطان في مخطط متعدد السنوات
للاحتيال على مستثمر
في شكوى هيئه الاوراق الماليه والبورصات
لمشاركتها في التلاعب المجتمع بافتتيتي
العمله الرقميه لشركه اف تي اكس وذلك
لكونها جزء من جهد اوسع لتعزيز الضمانات
المتاحه للاقراض من شركه
وفيما لم يقدم المدعي الامريكي تفاصيل
محدده بشان التهم الموجهه الى اليسون الى
ان لجنه الاوراق الماليه تدعي انهما حرضا
بنك على الاحتيالي على العملاء المدعي
العام اكد ان باتمان فرايد الذي تم توجيه
التهم اليه لائحه من التهام فعليا
بالاحتيال وغسل الاموال وانتهاكات تمويل
الحملات محتاجه حاليا لدى مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه بينما افادت اللجنه بان وانغ
انشا بابا خلفيا للبرامج في منصه اف تي
اكس ما سمح لشركه الميدا بتحويل اموال
العملاء الى صفقاتها الخاصه وبذلك اصبحت
اليسن واونج ثاني وثالث شخصين يتم
اتهامهما فيما يتعلق به افت اكس بمليارات
الدوله
[موسيقى]
هذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث شهر مارس هذا
العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
[تصفيق]
اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلن اليوم
في هذه اللحظه التاريخيه
الحمد المجلس النيابي
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم مشاهدينا ليست من القرن الماضي
بل هي صوره من شوارع كابو اليوم لفتيات
منعنا في القرن الواحد والعشرين من ابسط
لحقوقهن وهو حق التعليم بالعلم تبنى الامم
وترتقي الحضارات عمد الطلبان لحرمان
الفتيات من التعليم لكن الفتيات بدانا
معركه المقاومه ضد محاولاتي تجهيلهن
الى تصريح اليوم
باللغه الصعيد
الى الجنح للسلم فلد فلازم
لا تسعى الى تاجيج الحرب ولكن تسعى
لانهائها هذه التصريحات جاءت بعد اقل من
24 ساعه من تصريحات نوويه بالامس تحديدا
وخلال اعلان اهداف روسيا العسكريه للعمل
المقبل تحدثت عن الرد عن
على ضفه بحيره بن شعيف في منطقه زغرتا
بشمال لبنان اضيئت شجره عيد الميلاد
المصنوعه من زجاجات بلاستيكيه بلاستيكيه
معاذ تدويرها لنشر فرحه عيد الميلاد في
الوقت نفسه رفع الوعي من اجل الحفاظ على
البيئه تتالف الشجره من 110,000 زجاجه
بلاستيكيه خضراء تبرع بها السكان بالاضافه
الى الفيس زجاجه بيضاء زينت قمه هذه
الشجره
وننتقل الان الى الزميل عادل عيدان واخبار
الساعه وملفات جديده
الى اين ستذهب وما هي حلولها وبالتالي
ايضا لدينا الملف الروسي الاوكراني والحرب
حرب الكلام وتصعيد هذا الكلام بين موسكو
واشنطن